>> Harris: TITLE 42
RESTRICTIONS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH MEXICO ARE SET TO
END ON MONDAY, MAY 23.
WE HAVE SEEN IT COMING.
BUT A FEDERAL JUDGE COULD RULE
TODAY ON WHETHER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CAN EVEN LIFT
THE TRUMP-ERA PANDEMIC POLICY
WHICH HAS BEEN USED TO EXPEL A
MAJORITY OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
SINCE MARCH OF 2020.
THE LOOMING END OF TITLE 42 IS
STOKING FEARS OF AN EVEN LARGER
SURGE THAN THE RECORD NUMBERS
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN.
BORDER AGENTS REPORT 1800
APPREHENSIONS IN THE DEL RIO
SECTOR IN JUST THE PAST 24
HOURS ALONE.
700 IN THE LAST THREE DAYS IN
THE RIO GRANDE SECTOR.
CRITICS SAY VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS REMAINS
NOTICEABLY SILENT, ABSENT ON
THE CRISIS DESPITE BEING, WELL,
IN CHARGE OF IT ALL.
SHE IS THE BORDER CZAR.
>> OVER THE PAST 14 MONTHS
SINCE SHE GOT THAT TITLE, IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR TO EVERYBODY THAT
SHE DOES NOT EVER INTEND NOR
HAS SHE EVER TRULY INTENDED ON
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
SO MANY PEOPLE AT A CERTAIN
POINT LOOK AT THIS AND SAY YOU
KNOW, THE FACT THAT SHE IS NOT
EVEN PRETENDING TO TRY HERE
COUPLED WITH THE FACT OUR
GOVERNMENT CONTINUES TO ALLOW
OUR LAWS ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER
TO BE FLAGRANTLY VIOLATED ON A
DAILY BASIS.
PERHAPS THEY MAYBE DON'T CARE
MAYBE THIS ADMINISTRATION WANTS
THESE PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO
COME IN.
>> Harris: TENNESSEE SENATOR
MARSHA BLACK BURNS SERVES ON
SEVERAL COMMITTEES.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU IN PERSON.
LET'S JUST PICK IT UP WITH THE
BASIC MATH HERE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING
ALREADY.
IT IS ABOUT TO BECOME MORE.
GOP HAS STOOD IN THE WAY A
LITTLE BIT, THOUGH.
YOU ARE PROTECTING A AMERICA
FROM IT.
CAN YOU STAVE OFF WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN?
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO.
RIGHT NOW 6,000 PEOPLE PER DAY
IS WHAT THE BORDER PATROL IS
DEALING WITH.
WHEN TITLE 42 GOES AWAY THEY
ANTICIPATE -- THIS IS BORDER
PATROL'S NUMBER -- THAT IT WILL
BE 18,000 A DAY.
SO LOOK AT THAT, FROM 6,000 TO
18,000.
THE CARTELS ARE GLOBAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
LAST YEAR THEY BROUGHT PEOPLE
FROM 160 DIFFERENT COUNTRIES TO
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
AMONG THAT YOU HAD ABOUT 40
KNOWN TERRORISTS THAT WERE
APPREHENDED.
SO HARRIS, THIS IS WHAT THE
BORDER PATROL IS DEALING WITH.
AND THIS IS WHY FOR 30 YEARS
THEY HAVE BEEN SAYING WE NEED
THREE THINGS.
WE NEED A WALL, WE NEED BETTER
TECHNOLOGY, WE NEED MORE
OFFICERS AND AGENTS ON THE
GROUND.
AND THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOING TO GET THAT WALL.
THEY ARE NOT.
NOW TITLE 42 REMAIN IN MEXICO,
THINGS THAT HELPED THEM TO
STAVE OFF THE INFLUX OF THE
ILLEGAL ENTRY WHETHER IT'S
DRUGS, WHETHER IT'S HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, GANGS, SEX
TRAFFICKING.
NOW THAT IS GOING AWAY.
>> Harris: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
TERRORISM, THE POTENTIAL FOR IT
BECAUSE OF WHO IS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
FORMER ICE ACTING DIRECTOR
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP TOM HOMAN
TOLD ME THIS WEEK THAT ABOUT
700,000 GETAWAYS ARE THERE.
DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA OF HOW MANY
OF THEM COULD BE ON THAT
TERRORIST LIST?
>> NO, WE DON'T.
THERE ARE ABOUT 750,000 KNOWN
GOTAWAYS.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THEY SAW ON
SURVEILLANCE.
AND THEY COULDN'T GET THEM.
AND THESE ARE THE REALLY BAD
GUYS WITH THE DRUGS, THE
FENTANYL THAT IS KILLING SO
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
NOW HERE IS THE THING THAT
BORDER PATROL WILL TELL YOU,
AND I'M SURE WHETHER IT'S MARK
MORGAN OR TOM HOMAN.
YOU SEE SOME OF THE GOTAWAYS
BUT WHAT ABOUT THOSE YOU NEVER
SEE ON SURVEILLANCE?
IS THE NUMBER A MILLION?
IS IT 1.5 MILLION?
THEY DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS NOT A WAY TO QUANTIFY
THAT BECAUSE THERE IS NOT A
WALL, THERE IS NOT
SURVEILLANCE, THEY ARE NOT ABLE
TO SECURE PARTS OF THE BORDER
AND THEN TARGET THEIR RESOURCES
TO AREAS WHERE THERE CANNOT BE
A WALL.
THIS IS WHY BORDER PATROL HAS
SAID A PHYSICAL BARRIER SERVES
AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO PEOPLE
TRYING TO COME OVER.
>> Harris: VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS KNOWS THAT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A WALL.
HERE IS FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS INCREASING PUNISHMENT
FOR FENTANYL TRAFFICKING.
>> WE CAN AND MUST LOWER THE
DEMAND FOR DRUGS THROUGH
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH PROGRAMS
BUT WE ALSO MUST FIGHT THE
SUPPLY OF DRUGS AND CRACK DOWN
ON DEALERS AND TRAFFICKERS,
PARTICULARLY OF SUBSTANCES LIKE
FENTANYL.
WELL WILL DO ALL WE CAN TO
DECREASE THE PREVALENCE OF
FENTANYL IN FLORIDA AND THAT
MEANS IF YOU ARE DEALING
FENTANYL, YOU ARE KILLING
PEOPLE AND YOU ARE GOING TO BE
PUT IN JAIL.
>> Harris: COULD WE DO THAT AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL?
>> WE SHOULD BE.
I WAS TALKING WITH ONE OF MY
SHERIFFS IN NORTHWEST TENNESSEE
AND HE SAID MARSHA, 80% OF THE
DRUGS WE APPREHEND ARE EITHER
FENTANYL OR SOMETHING LACED
WITH FENTANYL.
THEY ARE EVEN TAKING GUMMY
BEARS AND ROLLING THEM IN
FENTANYL AND THIS IS HOW THEY
ARE GOING AFTER YOUNGER
CHILDREN THAT THEY CAN ADDICT
TO THIS.
80% OF THE DEATHS IN SOME OF
OUR COUNTIES ARE
FENTANYL-RELATED OVERDOSE
DEATHS.
THESE PEOPLE OUGHT TO BE LOCKED
UP.
THEY ARE CAUSING PEOPLE TO LOSE
THEIR LIVES.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY SELLING THESE
DRUGS AND THE BAD THINGS IS
THESE ARE CARTEL GROUPS THAT
ARE PUSHING THIS.
THEY HAVE SET UP THEIR HUBS IN
U.S. CITIES, A LOT OF THESE
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THEY ARE WORKING ON OUR SOIL
AND THEY ALL OUT TO BE LOCKED
UP.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET TO THE
BABY FORMULA BUT HAVE TO ASK
ABOUT THE VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS.
MIA, MISSING IN ACTION.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
DON'T SEE HERE.
SHE COMES EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE
TO BREAK A VOTE AND BREAK A TIE
ON A VOTE.
BUT I WISH THAT SHE WOULD TAKE
THE LEAD ON THE BORDER BECAUSE
THESE CARTELS ARE ABUSING WOMEN
AND CHILDREN, AND THAT NEEDS TO
STOP.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL LET YOU WRAP IT THERE AND
MOVE TO THIS.
CRITICS ARE ALSO LIGHTING UP
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OVER
THE BABY FORMULA EMERGENCY AND
HOW LONG IT HAS TAKEN FOR THEM
TO EVEN RECOGNIZE IT LET ALONE
TRY TO RESPOND TO IT.
HERE IS PENTAGON SPOKESPERSON
JOHN KIRBY TRYING TO EXPLAIN
HOW IMPORTS AND THE PRESIDENT
INVOKING THE DEFENSIVE
PRODUCTION ACT WILL WORK.
>> NOW JOB WILL BE TO WORK WITH
HHS, DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE,
FDA, TO HELP PROVIDE CONTRACT
COMMERCIAL AIR TO MOVE FORMULA
FROM OVERSEAS PARTICULARLY
EUROPE TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> Harris: BUT THAT STILL
DOESN'T TELL US HOW MUCH LONGER
SHELVES WILL REMAIN EMPTY.
PLEASE DO NOT DILUTE THE
FORMULA OR TRY TO MAKE YOUR OWN.
WHAT ARE THE OPTIONS AT THIS
POINT?
THE SUPPLY NATIONWIDE AVERAGING
AT LEAST 40% OUT OF STOCK.
SENATOR, I SPOKE WITH SENATOR
JOSH HAWLEY OF MISSOURI LAST
WEEK AND HE IS IN ONE OF THE
FIRST STATES WHERE THEY HIT THE
50% THRESHOLD AND HE SAID THEN
WE KNEW WE WERE IN TROUBLE
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT ENOUGH TO
HELP US NOW THAT IS IN THE
BLOODSTREAM.
>> YES, 54% OF THE BABY
FORMULAS ARE OUT OF STOCK IN
TENNESSEE, OUT OF STOCK.
AND YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR WEEKS TO THE WHITE
HOUSE GIVE SOME WAIVERS TO
IMPORT FROM CANADA, E.U., U.K.
AND THEY CHOSE NOT TO DO THAT.
>> Harris: WHY?
WHAT REASON DID THEY GIVE YOU?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
THEY JUST DID NOT DO THAT.
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE FACTORY IN
MICHIGAN AND HARRIS, THEY COULD
HAVE COULD HAVE OPENED.
THEY KNEW IN FEBRUARY THEY
SHOULD HAVE OPENED IT.
BACK THEN WE WERE AT A 25%
OUTAGE RATE AND THEY COULD HAVE
TAKEN CARE OF THIS.
THAT ONE FACTORY MAKES 40% OF
ALL THE BABY FORMULA IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Harris: IN THREE MONTHS,
LESS THAN THREE MONTHS WE WENT
FROM 25% TO OVER 50% IN YOUR
STATE OUT OF STOCK AND NOTHING
HAPPENED BETWEEN DOUBLING WHERE
OUR LOSSES WERE IN FEBRUARY?
>> WHAT DID THE ADMINISTRATION
DO?
THEY WAIT FOR A PROBLEM TO
BECOME A CRISIS, MAKE THE WRONG
DECISION AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
COME BACK AND TRY TO FIX IT.
WHICH IS WHAT THEY ARE DOING
NOW WITH THE WAIVERS AND WITH
THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT.
THIS NEVER NEEDED TO HAPPEN.
WE HAVE TWO CHILDREN IN
TENNESSEE THAT HAVE BEEN
HOSPITALIZED FOR LACK OF
FORMULA.
EVERY TIME I TALK WITH SOME OF
THESE PARENTS, IT IS VERY
EMOTIONAL.
I JUST -- I CANNOT EVEN -- YOU
ARE A MOM, I'M A MOM AND A
GRAND MOM, AND IT IS JUST HEART
WRENCHING WHAT THESE CHILDREN
ARE GOING THROUGH.
AND THEY ARE CALLING FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS IN OTHER
STATES AND SAYING CAN YOU SEE
IF YOU CAN FIND SOME?
I'LL PAY YOU TO FedEx IT TO ME.
>> Harris: WHAT YOU'VE TOLD ME
FROM THIS CONVERSATION IS THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE SIMPLY DOESN'T
HEAR OR DIDN'T HEAR AND NOW
THEY ARE TRYING TO PLAY
CATCH-UP.
THAT'S THE DANGEROUS GAME.
YOUNG LIVES ARE AT STAKE.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WE KNOW
THEY SAID THEY CARED.
DON'T THEY CARE NOW?
I JUST DON'T GET IT.
SENATOR, THANK YO